demain mardi s'annonce comme un nouveau
pic de la grève comme disent les
spécialistes avec de très nombreuses
manifestations notamment à paris ce qui
ne va pas arranger la circulation ce
lundi a déjà vu une extension tous
azimuts des conflits sociaux de ce
mouvement aux mille pattes mais sans
tête pour reprendre l'expression de mes
confrères d'infomatin le point elisabeth
lit dans les rues de bordeaux ce matin
beaucoup de voitures mais aucun bus ils
sont restés au garage
les 1200 chauffeur ayant suivi le mot
d'ordre de grève lancé par force
ouvrière
tant que le gouvernement juppé ne retire
pas son plan on continuera et je pense
que le mouvement va se durcir
sérieusement
entre marseille et aix-en-provence
péages gratuits sont atteints pour les
automobilistes pendant 1h30
il aurait offert par des manifestants au
df qui les informe des risques selon et
de la privatisation en angleterre ils
ont privatisé le gall de france s'est
traduit par 40% d'augmentation sur la
voiture pour les usagers et on veut
éviter ça
dans le nord les cheminots ont reconduit
la grève aucun train n'a circulé dans la
région aujourd'hui
situation identique demain avec toujours
les mêmes exceptions quatre
allers-retours d'eurostar paris
bruxelles et 5 paris londres qui sont
prévues pour demain en alsace à
fessenheim les grévistes d'edf se
relaient depuis cinq jours devant la
centrale ce matin ils ont bloqué
l'entrée pendant deux heures
une action qui fait partie d'un
mouvement tournant les grévistes
prévoient dès demain de s'attaquer à
d'autres sites